nous en manque un à ariha wii la wii en
bien mais on dirait mathieu donnart
monde et sans rigoler
mais ba ne ba de ferhat
non mais ça monte au nez c'est le gars
mais sur la tête de ma mère
mais en plus il a bien pareil que
matthieu lambeaux et quand tu t'appelles
mathieu belle mère quand je pense moi je
t'appelais matures non c'est un thème
bien mathieu delormeau
ces kits ont préféré dans l'équipe c'est
tout vous c'est vrai mon bébé tellement
bon tu me ressemble pas trop mais bon il
ya là quelque chose je te fais un bisou
tu fais quoi dans la vie
huit militaires ah ouais quand à tapas
le champ militaire a ouvert ses bras non
on va faire l'émission on va pas
l'émission fout de ma gueule du
satellite
regardez comme quoi la télé le foot
ouais c'est vrai mon chéri et ben ce
soit on va parler foot et touche pas à
mon poste monsieur savard exactement -
nikkei merci à l'épreuve a place to get
what you back mais toi l'abbé toile avec
toi va très bien